firefighters are struggling to control
six fast-moving wildfires burning across
a huge part of Southern California so
far one death has been linked to the
fires more than 700 buildings and homes
have been destroyed hundreds of
thousands of people were forced to flee
to safety the fires have burned 260
square miles that is bigger than the
size of Chicago Carter Evans is in
Escondido near San Diego with the latest
Carter good morning good morning from
Santa Barbara to San Diego some 8700
firefighters are slowly increasing
containment on these blazes now the
lilac fire here in San Diego County it
exploded on Thursday but Friday
firefighters caught a break when the
winds died down it may be December but
in Southern California warm dry in windy
conditions it kept weary firefighters
battling as many as six infernos at one
time when a tornado hits the Midwest
there's no stopping it when a hurricane
hits the East Coast there's no stopping
it win us the Santa Ana winds come in
there's no stopping them the largest
most destructive blaze the Thomas fire
in Ventura County has already burned
more than 200 square miles
some 400 structures have been reduced to
rubble and the fire is threatening
thousands more one flank now stretches
into the steep terrain of the Los Padres
National Forest we're still in the
firefight now we're still chasing fire
we're still building fire lines in
northern San Diego County the lilac fire
still rages when the winds subsided a
bit on Friday water dropping helicopters
attacked hotspots to marine and to Navy
choppers helped contain the flames some
guys aren't even getting breaks just
because of the way the Southern
California is right now and so we're
working our guys to the bone we've asked
made sure that they provide for safety
and just make sure that they can get
rest when need be dramatic cell phone
video captured hundreds of racehorses
being evacuated on Thursday when the
lilac fire over ran a training facility
it's just horrible it was sent inferno
on Friday hundreds of volunteers flocked
to the Del Mar racetrack bringing treats
for the horses this one sustained burns
to the neck and leg but is expected to
recover some 25 horses died trying to
escape the flames the string of
wildfires chased more than 200,000
people from their homes in the San Diego
area some evacuated to a local high
school just want to go home I just hope
and pray them our house is there some
300 engine companies from seven other
states have now joined the battle on
this fire the National Weather Service
says these hot windy conditions are now
expected to continue through Sunday
Anthony Carter Evans in Escondido
California thanks Carter